[Music]
there are
probably five and a half first
some people want to get into space uh
for uh national glory to
show how mighty a particular nation is
how advanced it is how in charge it is
second and this is related um there are
military reasons to want to go into
space
uh military to make sure that you can
secure
decent positions for your satellites to
make sure we know what other nations are
doing
uh to make sure other nations know that
we have the
uh wherewithal to obliterate them
if we if we would like to and this of
course is behind
the creation of the united states space
force
another reason to go to space of course
is scientific
curiosity just to figure out what's out
there and what's going on with it
um lots of different motivations there
to find out
what we're made of and where we came
from whether there might be life
elsewhere whether there may have been
life elsewhere
another reason is a frontierism um that
is supposed to be inherent to the human
condition like
it is the nature of man always to want
to
expand and do new things and
seek out new frontiers so there is is
said to
be um and it's usually it's often
politicians who are speaking this way an
inherent restlessness to the human
spirit
uh that space might let us enact this by
space might um
satisfy increasingly we have a desire to
go to space
for what i would call utopian reasons um
people want to go to space to start a
new society
to uh enact possibilities elsewhere that
we haven't been able to enact on earth
very similar to the kinds of uh reasons
that
um sort of rosy historians often
attribute to
the journey of europeans across the
atlantic to build a new life
in uh in the americas so those are the
five reasons
frontier glory militarism utopianism
scientific curiosity
the half one would be money
it is not yet a good bet
financially space space is super
expensive
there is so far not a lot of return on
your invent no return on your investment
at the moment it's all a totally
speculative economy
um but there are plenty of people who
are trying to imagine
a new space economy where materials for
example are
mined in space to build stuff we need in
space to put stuff in space
and if that new space economy emerges
then it might actually be possible to
make money in space and that would be
the place
and that would be another reason to go
[Music]
they're absolutely intertwined um but
they're not necessarily
all um working in concert with each
other sometimes they work against one
another sometimes they work
even antagonistically but they're all
working in relation to one another and
all of them depend on one another
um so for example there is a
massive frustration in the
what i would call the utopian scientific
community
with the slowness of nasa they move so
slowly you can't get them to they they
think of an idea and they're like all
right maybe 30 years in the future
this is what we'll do right um i'm using
i'm using a us example here um but
for the most part um nation-based space
agencies tend to be fairly slow china's
moving pretty fast um but historically
the nation-states move slowly um so the
corporate
um the corporate-based utopianism
of the contemporary space race is
um hoping to be able eventually to
sidestep
the nationally based space programs
entirely because they're just
so slow um national and international i
mean if
nations are slow the united nations are
even slower right
it's these political processes are so
slow um that
the the corporate utopian motivation for
getting into space wants to go faster
and faster and faster
it once ultimately decides to but in the
meantime
it relies upon those national structures
and those space programs
um to to to get it well early on for
funding
um and uh for resources
and for airspace and for so it's totally
reliant
upon the national structure that it's
totally frustrated with also and looking
to
to get itself free from um so this is
one kind of uh entanglement um similarly
seen from the other side
uh an outfit like nasa is a little bit
worried
about the corporate um
intentions of folks like elon musk and
jeff bezos and
even boeing but at the same time they
need it they need people to help bring
them
stuff bring stuff up to the
international space station they need
that so there's a this mutual reliance
um
scientists tend to be very wary of for
example
the militarizing of space and now
increasingly of the corporatizing of
space scientists themselves are
academic scientists very concerned about
this at the same time
they need the funding that comes through
those channels in order to fund the
projects that they're so
there's this um again i would call it
like an antagonistic
reliance of these different interests
upon one another
i'm concerned i am concerned that
when elon musk says in the small print
of the contract that one signs
to engage starlink satellite service
that mars is a free planet and no
earthly agency has sovereignty
over it that he is a laying claim
to a planet that first he's never been
on and none of us has ever been on that
doesn't necessarily doesn't belong to
anybody
um and it be this shows that he is
looking very much to find a way to
operate outside the
the constraints of national or
international law whether or not he ever
gets to mars he's looking to find a way
to operate outside the
constraints of national or international
law the man launched
a tesla roadster an entire car
into orbit around the sun
just because he felt like he could do it
and
it's not like there was he violated any
international regulation because nobody
thought to make a regulation about that
like he can't launch a car into space
so he just did this and now this is a
huge piece of
rubbish and if something does hit it it
becomes even more pieces of rubbish that
become more space garbage
um so he's just sort of tangential to
the law like he
he plays within it when he needs to he
doesn't when he doesn't need to
and i think that he's looking not to
have to um and the problem
again is the the slowness of the
legislative process
um that what i think we're going to see
playing what we're already seeing
playing out
we're going to see intensifying is
the legal logistics of
the frontier which in
earthly history at least has looked a
bit like
the existing national bodies
give a kind of freedom to some parties
those parties take that freedom to go do
new things on the frontier and then the
legal framework says oh wait hang on a
second
how do we catch up with that to figure
out
how to legislate the activity that is
already going on on the frontier
i don't think that earthly law first
knows what it's going to have to
legislate
not completely at least just so it
doesn't know how to write the laws that
are going to obtain
in space particularly when we have
permanent outposts in space
first and second it doesn't move quickly
enough it doesn't move as fast as
capital it doesn't move as fast as
corporations it doesn't move as fast as
messianic figures like elon musk
the corporate scientific structure is
bound up with
religion um that seems to be
a ridiculous claim um
corporations for the most part will say
we have absolutely nothing to do with
religion
um scientists of course always claim
that they have absolutely nothing to do
with religion
um but i do see a fascinating and
troubling
recapitulation reenactment of
some old european
religious themes in this
contemporary race to space um
and here's where i think you can find
them um you can find them first of all
in really boring easy to find places
um you can find them for example when
um mike pence two years ago said to the
national space council
we are going back to the moon and then
we're gonna go to mars and god's hand
will guide us quoting psalm
139 this is explicit invocation
of a divine justification
for a human adventure and specifically a
european descended
mainly white human adventure a very
wealthy human adventure
into the stars donald trump said just
about a year ago
uh that we are going back to the moon
and we were going to mars because it is
america's manifest
destiny to do so this concept of
manifest destiny
is an old and unsavory one the idea was
that god
wanted european descended
american citizens to expand throughout
the entire
north american continent enormous tracts
of land
were given to primarily white american
uh citizens um in the midwest and then
eventually in the west
um they they took those tracts of land
they farmed them they made homesteads
there this was the homesteading era
um but of course the us government could
only give this land
to light-skinned um european descended
people by taking it from native
americans so they forced native
americans off their land they forced
them into reservations they forced them
out of reservations they moved the
reservations
um they they they impaired many of them
they killed many of them they forcibly
relocated
so that uh white americans could fulfill
their their
allegedly um divine calling to
move across the continent um so
when trump says it is our manifest
destiny to go under the stars he is
saying
that that same story that same story
that justified
uh americans uh expansion over the
entire continent is now justifying this
sort of vertical extension
in the space he's explicitly invoking
god he's explicitly
invoking a transcendent reason um a
transcendent justification for america's
um self-assertion this is what
this is what he is doing explicitly but
then there's this there's a more subtle
way that religion is working here
there's a great scholar of religion
jonathan z
smith who used to say that there are two
major kinds of religions there's
there are lockative religions that stay
in one place
and try to make sure that the universe
holds together in the place that it's
always been
and there are utopian religions that say
you know what our real home our true
home is somewhere else it is out there
it is not where we are it is there it is
somewhere else
um and utopian religions of course
christianity is a is a
significant utopian religion um for the
most part christian traditions have
taught
that we are sojourners on this earth for
a time
and that eventually we will uh we will
die
and we will be reunited
with the the source of our being we will
be we will go back to the place that we
came from we will be
um uh reunited certainly with our loved
ones but also with our creator and that
our true home
is there in heaven somewhere else
so this utopian impulse to say
this earth is not our home is a
profoundly religious
impulse so this earth is not our home we
have a home somewhere else
in some place that you can only imagine
that you've never seen experientially
mars
is only a little more filled in for us
than like heaven
that impulse to promise a perfect
existence elsewhere in a
truly inaccessible other realm um
is a profoundly religious impulse and in
this way elon musk himself um
really is a kind of self-appointed
messiah a self-appointed savior who's
saying
how dare you say that i am in this for
the money
how dare you say that i'm in this for
the glory i am looking to
save humanity but what this promise
to save humanity relies on is
a previous um drumming
up of the threat of disaster elon musk
can only sell the salvation he's selling
by convincing all of us that there is an
imminent disaster
that we are um we are about to be
obliterated in some way that earth is
about to become
uninhabitable for human beings earth
can't sustain human beings
so increasingly you're hearing among the
kind of spacenick community
um that uh earth is done
earth is done there is it is no longer
going to be able to support life
uh it is certainly not going to be able
to support um the number of human beings
uh we are we are filling the earth with
something is going to wipe us out
climate disaster or maybe a virus
disaster and
faced with this imminent disaster we are
going to have to find somewhere else to
go it's a sort of two step that elon
musk is making disaster and salvation
there's a coming disaster i am your way
out i'm your ticket out somewhere else
[Music]
so jeff bezos is a different kind of
space savior
jeff bezos might be more of a locket of
type so besos is selling a different
kind of vision
which is to say he's not abandoning the
earth he's
looking to restore the earth by
making us
[Music]
[Music]
the current pace of life is immutable
that there is no other way to be that of
course
we all have to be this technological
this
consumptive this comfortable our only
option is to abandon the earth either by
leaving it forever a lamas
or by leaving it to itself a la bezos
but what neither of them is asking
is um is there not any other way to live
upon the earth is there not any other
way to live
here
it is on the one hand sincere and not a
front and what i mean is i think that
musk and visas are
genuinely convinced that
humanity is good their their
understanding of humanity which is this
um sort of universal uh assumption
of a particular kind of human that they
spend a lot of time with um but
that humanity is good that humanity is
worth
saving and that humanity this salvation
of humanity is worth
any kind of like any effort that we can
put into it at all costs
okay um i do not believe that
they are selling the mars and
rotating spheres stories just
as a means to increase tesla's stock or
uh increase amazon's or blue origin
stock or something like that i don't i
don't think it is that
sinister i think they they really do
think that they can save people
on the other hand um
the people they intend to save can only
be
a very small um very privileged
subset of humanity along with
a slightly larger very underprivileged
subset of humanity that is willing to
work for those people and make their
lives very comfortable
because you don't get 74 degrees perfect
maui
weather everything working great without
a whole host
of humans and robots who are laboring
constantly to make sure that that
privileged class feels comfortable
is musk going to save the human race
well if you imagine that by by
transporting
some people to mars um and letting
everybody else fend for themselves on
earth
that constitutes salvation sure um do we
have any vision
of getting everybody off planet or
getting
everybody saved absolutely not no no no
no it's going to be some super wealthy
people
and laborers
[Music]
it's not a universal human idea the idea
that it's
uh okay and even necessary for a subset
of humanity
uh to go elsewhere and take that land
for example
the university of hawaii and nasa have
been trying for years to construct a
13th telescope on mauna kea
to you know see farther back into the
cosmos than we have been able to see
with other terrestrial
uh telescopes native or kanaka hawaiians
have said
please don't construct this telescope
it's not in the sacred it is the
inhabitation of the ancestors it is
itself an ancestor it's the connection
between the heavens and the earth
it's immensely important to indigenous
hawaiians and we are
begging you please not to construct
another telescope here
and degrade the land further and degrade
the indigenous
life forms that are there and to move
them off their mountain
the big difficulty here is not so much a
political one
and not so much a scientific one it's
like a metaphysical misunderstanding and
it's an ethical misunderstanding
as to what counts as life and
what counts as worthy of protection for
the most
part western scientists and western
politicians think of mountains as
resources as things that are there for
humans to
use as they need to use them for
recreation
or for uh for um extraction
of fuel or things like that or um
or as a location as a place to be um
for indigenous hawaiians the mountain
isn't a resource it's not a location
it's an ancestor it's a sacred site it's
a
it's a temple you have to relate to it
you have to interact with it as a person
in its own right
the difficulty here is um in
seeing that it could be that land itself
has rights and land itself has purse and
land itself ought to be taken care of
so if we were to take that understanding
that land itself has rights and land
itself
um needs to be cared for
and related to rather than just
exploited and used
um we might get a really different
picture of what it's all right to do
say on mars or what it's all right to do
on the moon or what it's all right to do
on an
asteroid um is it okay
to go to the moon and put
a mind there and to establish little
outposts dude like did the moon ask us
it
may sound like a ridiculous question but
like is that all right and these are
questions that i would like us to ask
and i think that there are questions
that um numerous different communities
uh on our planet including indigenous
hawaiians including aboriginal
australians who have their own
long history of astronomy might
help uh western explorers to
ask and answer about how it's possible
to relate
ethically to land that is not on the
earth
um to other other kinds of landforms
[Music]
i think that there are ways to enable
beautiful conversations particularly
between say indigenous activists on the
one hand and scientists on the other
by means of a shared attention to the
importance of
land scientists love land
scientists you know geologists love
rocks they often talk about
the life cycle of rocks right rocks
which are which i think
you know kind of ordinary western
everyday people like me tend to think
are just like just rocks a geologist
doesn't think a rock is just a rock a
geologist thinks that a rock
you know begins in some kind of well
begins it's like star stuff and then
becomes a mountain and then it falls off
the mountain and then it goes into the
sea
and then it gets kicked around and then
it gets moss on it and then some
somebody retrieves it from the
like it has a hole and then it becomes
sand right um a rock has a whole kind of
life cycle
western scientists do not need to adopt
the beliefs or the language of
indigenous people
in order to say
that rocks for example are important
um that rocks for example should be uh
cared for and attended to rather than
just blasted
for a human profit so i actually think
that there's a
massively productive conversation that
can happen between um
the protectors of the land on our
planet um and western scientists about
the importance of
um what we often call inanimate objects
right
and even the personhood in the
livelihood of inanimate objects
um i think there was a great case to be
made
for western scientists to say um
if it is primarily important from a
scientific
standpoint to learn about the history of
mars but what happened there about
whether or not there was like what kind
of life there were
then we need to proceed as delicately as
possible so we don't
wreck it so we can understand so we
don't um destroy that
archaeological site before we learn
anything from it
um so there are lots of different ways
of talking about the importance of the
landscape and again
westerners don't have to steal other
people's stories in order to think that
that rocks are important but it's
important to listen to those other
stories and then
say okay what is it within this
scientific viewpoint
that's actually saying a similar thing
in its own kind of language in its own
right
what might be western scientific reasons
not just to sort of terraform mars or
blast it
in order to extract or blast the moon in
order to extract resources from it
um that's a great conversation the
conversation between say indigenous
activists
uh and um the commercial sector is a
harder one
that's a harder one um and even between
the scientific sector and the commercial
sector can be can be a more difficult
one once we introduce
the issue of commerce once we introduce
the
um what seems now to be an imperative to
expand the earthly economy into space to
start a new economy in space
uh there i think very little
conversation is
possible between people who
respect land and land formations for its
own
sake and people who are looking to
make a profit and create a new economy
in space
um and unfortunately that sector
of um commercial interests in space
is very handily supported
by the utopian interest in space because
it is it becomes a very
smooth argument to make to say
look we need a new space economy because
earth is about to kill us and we have to
go somewhere else and so that economy is
going to support the future
of humanity so you know you might be
obsessing over the personhood of rocks
or something like that but in the
meantime i'm trying to save humanity
so the utopia and the corporate
interests work very nicely with one
another
no i do not think that scientific
progress
and uh indigenously
inspired anti-colonial
work are opposed at all
i think it is possible to make
scientific
progress um in a respectful
careful and non-exploitative
way so it is possible to send
um uncrewed missions
to mars hopefully to venus to find out
what's going on there to learn those
robotic missions can
give us all kinds of information about
what's going on there we can make
tons of scientific progress we could put
gosh we could put satellites near them
near near mars we could put satellites
out by
venus there are some but we could you
know we could get we could get all sorts
of scientific data
and learn and learn and learn through
minimal minimally invasive
uh and minimally destructive and
minimally polluting
um uncrewed missions to other planets
we're already doing it
and we can we can continue to uh to
expand
there um
the question of colonizing other planets
isn't to my mind a question of
scientific progress at all
that's a sign that's that's that's
ideological progress
um that's a different kind of progress
is it possible
to colonize mars in
a respectful anti-colonial
indigenously attentive way i don't know
i have no idea but that conversation
needs to be had and that's a more
complicated question um is it possible
to reconcile untrammeled corporate
interest and profiteering with a
respectful
gentle way of living on in the cosmos no
no absolutely not i don't think there is
[Music]
about a decade ago there was some
talk of inscribing a pepsi logo on the
moon
so that that's what we see instead of
looking at the moon
many people across political spectrums
and differences
uh can agree that that is somehow
too much the question is whether
other kinds of activities on the moon
and on mars and on
asteroids even are
can be called sort of similarly
disrespectful
um there are people who will say
um these bodies are not ours
they are their own we don't have any
right to go up there and do
anything to them we don't even have a
right to put a rover on them we don't
have a right to we certainly don't have
a right to put a mind there
there are people who will argue this um
i am a bit of an agnostic
with respect to the question of whether
it is
important to leave all planetary bodies
all other planetary bodies alone because
they're not ours i am an agnostic
um but i do think it's important to ask
how well we have treated the planet
that we do think about as ours that we
do
think about as our home and as available
to us
um and to ask like how that's going the
thing that's interesting is that the
anti-space crew
and the pro-utopian space crew actually
all agree
we haven't done a great job um with
respect to stewardship of the earth we
haven't done a great job of preserving
our biosphere of preserving our home um
we can all agree on that
so then the question becomes is it
possible
to inhabit another planet
without just repeating the same problems
and what i'm concerned about is if
the forces that have degraded and
destroyed this planet
are the forces of a particularly
technologized approach to science not
science itself but a particularly
technologized instrumentalizing approach
to science
resource extraction um the forced
colonization of other peoples for the
sake of non-european peoples for the
sake of extracting resources and
accumulating wealth if those are the
forces
that have contributed to the degradation
of this planet
why are those the forces we're allowing
to go to other planets
to establish new habitats there
send somebody else send somebody send
anybody else but don't send the
technocrats
[Music]
the importance of the world of this
world of this world and all of its
flawed ridiculousness
everything we are and everything we have
and all the places we are going are the
product of
this world things are not going to get
better elsewhere
this world is what is deserving of our
attention and our concern
and our respect and our reverence and
our thanks i think that that could
help for more debates talks and
interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv